like why would he wait when the last
guys got it for free because men because
men value Purity that's why it's going
to have somebody that's on the same
level as you so for example now I know
that I'm on this this journey it's not
50 50. so I'm saying like there aren't
enough men in the church for the women
oh what like they're not you can't say
like oh we should all wait because
they're not there I'm not saying wait
because you can still go out and speak
to guys but you kind of have to use
discernment and know that okay I have to
go for a guy that's ready to wait for me
you get me so that's why you have to be
wise when you're dating but to me like
what I'm saying is like I think that
keeps women single because I don't think
there's a lot of guys that are willing
to do that because
I know but I think the the real thing is
like it's like you made your bed lie in
it and if you want it if you want it I
mean it's if we want to live in a
fantasy world where all these guys are
dying to wait for born-again virgins but
they're not